did 95 of diets actually fail so this
statistic has been floating around for
like decades and for those who have been
dieting it's depressing us the good news
is that it's actually BS and it was
based on a really shitty study from the
50s so if your chances are better than
five percent how good are they well
different diets will often tell
different success rates but most Studies
have really poor retention rates and
only will follow participants for like 3
to 16 months Max the best site that we
have is the eight year long look ahead
trial this study found that by the eight
year mark half of their 2500
participants kept off at least five
percent of their Baseline weight a
quarter kept off at least 10 percent and
around 10 percent kept off at least 15
percent it's not mind-blowing but it is
certainly a lot better than the 95 of
diets fail rule but if you want some
insight into what increases people's
chances of long-term weight loss success
leave me a comment below